In 2007, Steve Jobs taught us the
greatest copywriting lesson we could
ever learn, and that is sell with
benefits, not features. Okay, so check
this out. When they released the new
iPod, they could have said 5 GB of
storage, that is a feature that that
iPod had is it dropped an enormous
amount of storage back in 2007, but
instead they said 1,000 songs in your
pocket. 5 GB of storage is a feature of
your product, but the benefit is what
matters to the buyer. What does the
buyer get for the feature of your
product? Don't talk about the feature.
Talk about the benefit your buyer wants
and you will sell infinitely more of
your product because now you are buyer
facing instead of looking at herself.